- [Instructor] In this
video, we're going to try
to get a sense of what the
limit as x approaches three
of x to the third minus 3x squared
over 5x minus 15 is.
And when I say get a sense,
we're going to do that
by seeing what values for
this expression we get
as x gets closer and closer to three.
Now, one thing that you
might want to try out,
is, well, what happens to this expression
when x is equal to three?
Well, then, it's going to
be three to the third power
minus three times three squared
over five times three minus 15.
So at x equals three, this
expression's going to be,
and let's see, in the
numerator, you have 27 minus 27,
zero, over 15 minus 15, over zero.
So this expression is actually
not defined as x equals three.
We get this indeterminate form.
We get zero over zero.
But let's see, even though the function,
even though the expression is not defined,
let's see if we can get a sense
of what the limit might be.
And to do that, I'm
going to set up a table.
So, let me set up a table here.
And actually I'm going
to set up two tables.
So this is x and this is x to the third
minus 3x squared over 5x minus 15.
Actually, I'm going to do that again,
and I'll tell you why in a second.
So, this is gonna be x,
and this is x to the third
minus 3x squared over 5x minus 15.
The reason why I set up two tables,
I didn't have to do two tables.
I could have done it all in one table,
but hopefully, this will make it
a little bit more intuitive
what I'm trying to do,
is on this left table,
I'm gonna, let's try out x values
that get closer and close to three
from the left, from values
that are less than three.
So for example, we could
go to 2.9 and figure out
what the expression equals
when x is 2.9, but then
we could try to get even a
little bit closer than that.
We could go to 2.99,
and then we could go
even closer than that.
We could go to 2.999, and so,
one way to think about it here
is as we try to figure out
what this expression equals
as we get closer and closer to three,
we're trying to approximate
the limit from the left.
So, limit from the left.
And why do I say the left?
Well, if you would think about
this on a coordinate plane,
these are the x values, so
they're to the left of three,
but we're getting closer
and closer and closer.
We're moving to the right,
but these are the x values
that are on the left side
of three, that are less than three.
But we also, in order
for the limit to exist,
we have to be approaching the
same thing from both sides,
from both the left and the right.
So we could also try to approximate
the limit from the right,
and so what values would those be?
Well, those would be x
values larger than three,
so we could say 3.1,
but then we might wanna
get a little bit closer.
We could go 3.01, but
then we might wanna get
even closer to three.
3.001, and every time we get
closer and closer to three,
we're gonna get a better approximation,
or we're gonna get a better sense
of what we are actually approaching.
So let's get a calculator out and do this,
and you could keep going, 2.999999,
3.000001.
Now, one key idea here to point out
before I even calculate
what these are going to be,
sometimes when people say
the limit from both sides
or the limit from the left
or the limit from the right,
they imagine that the limit
from the left is negative values
and the limit from the
right are positive values.
But as you can see here,
the limit from the left
are to the left of the x value
that you're trying to find the limit at.
So these aren't negative values.
These are just approaching the three
right over here from
values less than three.
This is approaching the three
from values larger than three.
So let's see.
Let's calculate the
value of this expression
when x is equal to 2.9.
So we have 2.9
to the third power
minus three times 2.9 squared,
which is, close the parentheses,
so that's our numerator,
and then divided by,
open parentheses, five times 2.9 minus 15,
that's our denominator,
is equal to, let's see,
I got about 1.682.
1.682.
So now let's keep going.
So, let's see.
If we do 2.99 to the third power
minus 3 times 2.99 squared
is equal to, and then we divide that
by our denominator, open parentheses,
five times 2.99 minus 15
is equal to 1.78802.
Well, I'll just found that to 1.788,
approximately 1.788,
and now let's get even closer to three.
Remember, we're now approaching
three from the left,
so 2.999 is even that
much closer to three.
So let's get the calculator out again,
and we get...
Now we get 2.999 to the third power
minus three times, open
parentheses, 2.999 squared,
close parentheses.
So that's our numerator.
Divided by, open parenthesis,
fives times 2.999 minus 15
is equal to 1.7988 or
approximately 1.7988.
Approximately 1.7988.
So it seems to be getting
closer and closer to 1.8,
and you could even verify.
Try 2.9999, see if it's
getting closer to 1.8.
So this is our limit from the left.
Now we could try the limit from the right.
So what happens when we try 3.1.
So 3.1 to the third power
minus three times, open
parentheses, 3.1 squared,
close parentheses, that's our numerator,
divided by, open
parentheses, five times 3.1
minus 15, that's our
denominator, is equal to 1.922.
1.922.
All right, let's keep going.
This is something
strangely fun about this.
All right, so let's see when x is 3.01.
So now we're approaching
x equals 3 from the right,
from values that are larger.
We're getting closer
and closer and closer.
We're approaching from the right,
but we're moving towards the left,
towards x equals three, without
equaling x equals three.
So now let's do 3.01 to the third power
minus three times, open parentheses,
3.01 squared, closed parentheses.
That's our numerator.
Divided by, open
parentheses, five times 3.01
minus 15, close parentheses,
is equal to 1.81,
I'll say roughly 1.812,
approximately 1.812.
It does look like we're
approaching 1.8 from above, now,
but let's just get even closer, 3.001.
So we can finish at least
what I put on our tables here.
If you're unsure, you can
just keep getting closer
and closer and closer,
3.0000001 if you're interested.
But let's just do this one.
3.001 to the third power
minus three times 3.001 squared,
close parentheses, that's our numerator,
divided by, open parentheses,
five times 3.001 minus 15,
that's our denominator,
is equal to roughly 1.801.
So approximately 1.801.
So based on what we're
seeing here, I would make
the estimate that this looks
like it's approaching 1.8,
so is this equal to 1.8.
As I said, in the future,
we're going to be able to find
this out exactly, but if
you're not sure about this,
you could try even closer
and closer and closer values.
Actually, just for kicks,
let's just do a super close value.
Let's do 2.99999.
Let's see what that gets us.
So we're getting really close.
We're approaching from the left,
but we're getting really
close to three now.
So let me get the calculator out here.
Okay, so how many is that?
That is five nines.
So two point one, two, three, four, five,
to the third power,
minus three times,
and we're gonna have two point
one, two, three, four, five, squared,
close parentheses.
That's our numerator.
Divided by five times two point
one, two, three, four, five,
2.99999, minus 15, that's our denominator,
is equal to, notice, we got even closer.
In fact, if we round this at all,
this is going to be 1.8.
So yeah, if we round it
to the nearest thousandth,
this is going to...
Yeah, if we round this to
the nearest thousandth,
this is going to be 1.8.
So we're getting very close here to 1.8,
and if you're not feeling good about that,
you could go even closer
and closer and closer
to three to feel better and
better and better about it.
Once again, we're approximating it.
We're seeing, what is the
behavior as we get closer
and closer to three from
the left and from the right.
And not only is this valuable
for calculating limits,
and sometimes you would have
to calculate them numerically
like this, but it also
gives you an intuition
for what a limit is all about.